I got a call from a very drunk band
how dare you really
might as well start off with
a bam is running from the law hiding in
the woods threatening to kill people
this all according to TMZ it's pretty
unreal
um how long do you guys hear it before
it hits the new cycle or do you pretty
much hear about it as it hits the new
cycle okay
here's
oh wow
glad you asked there's uh I'm not
necessarily glad you asked but there's
this um subreddit
strictly devoted to people talking about
Bam Margera and
um it is absolutely insane how fast yeah
news develops on the let's talk bam
subreddit and um that's what it's called
let's talk bam let's talk bam I've never
been to Reddit before but I just I heard
about this bam page and and I went and
checked it out and uh
there are some resourceful people on
there and a lot of it's really funny a
lot of it's really sad a lot of it's uh
breaking news but
um I'm pretty sure that's where TMZ is
getting all of the Scoops is from
Serenity you really think TMZ is getting
it from Reddit I think people on Reddit
are feeding it to TMZ okay and
um you know the stuff breaks on Reddit
it goes to TMZ yeah but wow I mean we
have had the gnarliest week ever and I
don't even know where to begin with uh
the prostitutes with the the key
stirring but um I do want to just wrap
up the BAM talk a little bit
um he
found out about this this uh free bam
movement which is just the
the most lunatic stuff he's just finding
out about it now there's speculation
about whether he knew and forgot or
whether he's lying saying that he never
knew who knows but uh there's a
particular learning person in charge of
this whole operation and he found out
about this loony lady and asked to do an
interview with her and uh according to a
lot of people he's
many days into a meth Bender like
smoking crystal meth and drinking
alcohol and going to do interviews with
this loony lady and it seems that just
about as soon as he got out of uh her
presence
like he's assaulting people and
threatening to kill people and hiding in
the woods I mean you know recording this
on Wednesday American time and uh it'll
come out on Thursday and without a doubt
in just the 24 hours between now and
when this comes out there will be lots
of news like that's what's so crazy
about his subreddit is that yeah it's
pretty wild I mean it's crazy that
people are like yeah come on my podcast
and talk while he's on meth like right
that's kind of gnarly I'm really really
glad that number one we never had bam on
the podcast when he was intoxicated
he he died allegedly allegedly but like
I mean but he was in a place where he
shouldn't have been well whenever we've
spoken to the BAM on the podcast he's
been
presentable yeah yeah
he's been
lovely to deal with right and when he
was on tour with us it was it wasn't bad
when he was on tour with this it was
awesome yeah and and I went ahead and
just scrapped all of that footage oh did
you scrap it it's never gonna see the
light of day I remember what are you
gonna do with it yeah yeah even though
it has its moments of heartwarming and
yeah we probably could have made a lot
of money if we sold those bam
skateboards for sure but it's all out
the window
so take that anybody who thinks uh God
I'm so glad I got one of those boards
yeah I made a lot of money too did you
you haven't even talked about what you
were going to do with that money too I
mean I did want to
um you know help create a trust fund for
Phoenix but then
um with Nikki filing for uh legal
separation Soul custody like this and
that like now there's a whole new
Wrinkle in it where you know we're going
to be talking about alimony we're going
to be talking about child support and
he's gonna have to pay that anyway so I
did suggest hey why don't we sell these
skateboards and have
um you know have uh money go straight to
cover
Phoenix child support alimony like
whatever like that's coming out of your
pocket either way and when I made that
suggestion
uh I got a call from a very drunk band
how dare you really I I did my work I
worked you know that's you know and I
was like
Bam um I've paid you for everything you
did I'm talking about anything in the
future you know that has not happened
yet like for me to do more in the future
yeah I really just you know wouldn't and
I don't care this is the first day that
he uh uh posted the challenge Knoxville
to the the oh to the boxing minute no
glove box Jesus
I'm just
I you know I was I was laying in the in
the shower just laying on the ground
just soaking the the the the water over
me and thinking about it I was like this
craziness with bam I
what I'm so sad about is that
that if he was happy and healthy
like Not only would he would he be
thriving
if he was sober and and productive he'd
be thriving but the two of us would be
so much stronger together for sure I
mean you look at like
Tom Segura and Bert Kreischer and how
much stronger they are together because
of the two bears in one cave and stuff
and I just think about the opportunities
that we could have had yeah
but there are no opportunities because
all this is going on and and as far as
him being running from the cops and and
hiding in the woods like whatever is
going on I hope to God that he gets
arrested I hope to God that the family
because at that points the taxpayers are
just paying for him to go to jail and
detox right I mean that's kind of
instead of him coming out of pocket 50
Grand a month maybe the actual jail time
will force him and give him enough time
away from the drugs right here it's like
okay I'm sober for a little bit that's
the one thing that hasn't tried yet yeah
exactly and furthermore it's the like
and sitting in jail is the only place
where everybody can have a reasonable
expectation that he's safe yeah that
he's not harming himself or others is
that a good segue for jail talk
my point with the taxpayers was I
remember like 15 years ago or something
when I was going through it with a
family member I was watching Dr Drew and
he was just like you know if you're
suspecting somebody's drunk driving and
it's been enough like call the cops on
them get them arrested have them and I
that just kind of always stuck out with
me but that's why I brought that up and
and
everybody's smoking meth I'm always been
pretty careful not to make that
allegation myself even though
um you know like it would seem that it'd
be pretty easy to set up uh
some situation where he could be
arrested for that that'd probably be the
best thing that ever happened to him
yeah but it sounds like his charges now
are a little bit more serious than that
yeah they're all misdemeanors they're uh
terroristic threats for telling multiple
people he wants to put a bullet in their
head a terrorist threat is just a
misdemeanor I want to put a bullet in
your head is what earned the terroristic
threat as I understand it and it's on he
didn't get a charge for taking the car
no no charge for taking the car because
uh it was legitimately borrowed to his
crazy girlfriend and she just never gave
it back
and that's how he inherited a daughter
uh he's talking about how he has a
daughter now yeah he's talking about how
he has a daughter and with all of this
crazy psycho stuff it seems that this
poor eight-year-old girl is in tow being
subjected to all of it so there was a
point when like in and around where the
car was taken that uh apparently the
eight-year-old girl was left uh April's
right yeah with April yeah and uh I mean
I guess the I guess there's a break you
know that she's not with bam running
from the cops and you know uh with all
the things going on but
I for April I mean if he goes to jail at
least you can sigh relief where she
knows where she he is yeah right that's
like uh okay now I know he's not [__]
Woods you know I hope to God that he
doesn't die I hope to God that the band
the family will press charges do
whatever it takes to get him because
it's the one thing we haven't seen yet
we haven't tried that yet I think that
jail I think I'm so scared of being in
jail that that's the one thing but do
you think with these charges not being
that serious he'll actually get but
there's so many charts I mean like
four or five but wouldn't a judge look
at the last four years and be like
hopefully okay then let me ask you this
would would somebody like bam go to uh
protective custody where they go like in
the mix with everybody or get like
spectacular custody for sure the whole
time yeah yeah he would be absolutely
totally safe there's no way that they
would let him be in contact with other
prisoners other other inmates there's no
way and and for that matter anytime
somebody with uh any kind of Fame
is in jail
there's no upside for the jail something
bad happened to that person the Jail's
screwed right like all of a sudden that
Jail's under a microscope like they they
want to get celebrities kind of out of
there because there's no benefit to the
jails for having them in there is my
understanding which doesn't help the
kids because it would be better if if uh
if he was in there okay spot you think
it would be better if he was in general
no no no I just think it'd be better if
he was in jail oh if he was in jail in
general yeah I think that that you know
but it's just so scary man it's so scary
like how crazy and and bad this is like
now like I was afraid when I woke up
today in Australia we're so many hours
ahead that we wake up and it's already
evening back home yeah and I'm like what
happened today you know am I gonna turn
on my phone turn off do not disturb and
find out terrible news do you think that
Bam's like so addicted to meth that when
he does get caught and goes to jail he's
going to key through some meth to get in
there
I have a cheek heard that you need in
your life it's called ag1 from athletic
greens it is the most comprehensive and
convenient not to mention delicious
nutritional supplement you can get if
you go to
athleticgreens.com
Stevo with your first purchase you can
get five convenient comprehensive ag-1
travel packs plus an entire year's
supply of immune boosting Vitamin D it
is a great deal I encourage you to jump
on it and to do so again go to
athleticgreens.com
steva
yeah dude